thanks to sophie for sponsoring a
portion of this video hey guys it's
justine and today i want to talk to you
guys about a topic
that is always coming up pretty much for
the past 15
years that i've been creating content
here online the question is how do
creators make money
online and it is different for everyone
so everyone does have a very unique
story but there are a lot of crossover
and similarities i think with mine and a
lot of people who are also making
content today but for years everyone is
always asking me how
i make money and how did i get to where
i am today
and a lot of times they will assume that
it's some sort of overnight success or
some sort of just
something that happened magically and
while i wish that that was the case
i would say it's safe to say that most
people regardless of their success level
hasn't had an easy road to get to where
they are or it's not going to be an easy
road to get to where they want to go so
today
a portion of this video is sponsored by
sofi and when they came to me interested
in sponsoring a video
i just was thinking of so many video
ideas that i could just casually mention
their product and then carry on with my
video like usual
but i really wanted this to kind of be
different because i feel like sometimes
not talking about money
is actually a detriment to the entire
community and not just the entire
community but to people who are just
starting out and have no concept of this
world
i feel like there's so much that i
didn't learn in school or even in
college about
the industry that i'm in because it was
something that i sort of i guess
fell accidentally into and sort of
created it as i went
so i really wanted this video to kind of
answer a lot of those serious questions
that people have about making money
online
about my history of making content and
how i managed to get to where i am today
and hopefully i can offer you guys some
answers but also most importantly some
inspiration
and i'm so grateful for brands like sofi
who are kind enough to trust creators
like me to share their message and
product with all of you guys so first
let me tell you guys about sofi and then
we can get more into it so far members
can have a suite of financial products
that are available to them that all can
work together to help you guys achieve
your financial goals
it lets you save spend earn borrow and
invest
all in one app i also really love the
community aspect where they offer
complimentary financial planners to sofa
members to talk to you one-on-one to
walk you through a financial game plan
for so many people in the u.s our
college debt is something that just
seemingly takes forever to pay off i
know i'm so lucky that my parents were
able to help with a portion of my
tuition and they also helped me apply
for a lot of different scholarships that
i was eligible for
but after graduation i was still left
with a huge portion of that loan that
was my part to cover so after i
graduated and then many
many years later after i finally started
creating content on youtube
after having several jobs i worked as a
graphic designer i also worked as a
video producer and editor at a
chiropractor i did talk a lot about this
stuff in my book so some of you guys
might already know this story
but the one thing that i did when i
finally started getting success on
youtube was putting as much money
possible as i could to pay off my
student debt but not without incurring
so much interest that it still upsets me
to this day to think about it
i do really wish that there was
something like sofi back then
this is easily accessible as it is now
sofi is a private lender that offers
student loan refinancing that can save
you thousands of dollars on your student
loans there's a simple online
application that you can fill out and
you're able to check your rate online
in about two minutes so how it works is
they pay off your existing loan and then
they give you a new loan with new terms
and it costs nothing to refinance and
has the potential to save you a lot over
time there is one important thing to
note though we
are still in such a strange time with
covid so due to the cares act extension
that goes at least through the end of
september it's not advisable to
refinance your federal student loans
right now
you should wait and watch what happens
with the cares act but if you do have
private student loans
refinancing could be a great option they
also offer personal loans and home loans
as well so that can help you achieve
other goals of buying refinancing or
remodeling a home
or just paying off stubborn high
interest credit card debt
which i have definitely been there i'll
put a link in the description if you're
interested in checking out so far
thank you again to sophie for sponsoring
a portion of this video so now we're
gonna head into answering some of your
questions and the first one
is surprise this was a sponsored video
and that is one of the main ways that i
am very fortunate enough to be able to
make money here on youtube
and it's interesting because i've talked
to a lot of my creator friends and a lot
of them
say that that is not their main source
of income i've been very lucky that a
lot of my content over the years has
been super brand friendly
and the way that i've kind of structured
my content which is yes
it is an intentional thing is to be able
to integrate really great brands into my
videos
one of the things that i've noticed
though specifically about the tech space
is being very careful to not
sometimes call a sponsored video a
review since it is sponsored
sometimes people feel like they're
paying for a review so kind of my new
mindset
is i'm gonna show you this cool thing i
would not be showing you this cool thing
if i didn't actually like it i do turn
down a ton of brand deals
where i'm not actually into the product
so if i'm showing you guys something
here
it may not be a full comprehensive
review if it is a sponsored video it is
something that i'm showing you guys that
i think is cool and hopefully you guys
will enjoy it as well so sometimes
there's a couple of different ways that
i'll work with brands we'll either do
like a full
integrated video so the entire video
will be about said
product or something like this video
where the integration kind of happened
at the beginning and so they just
sponsor kind of a portion of the video
but even though just that portion was
sponsored i felt like this was such an
important topic that i really wanted to
kind of open the dialogue
have a conversation and then continue
this conversation either in the comments
or on twitter
or i don't know like maybe we'll do like
a clubhouse or something one of the
biggest issues is a lot of us not
talking about these things because
unfortunately
in this industry and basically the
entire
world in general there's a lot of people
who really don't care about you and
there's a lot of very shady businesses
out there
and they will try to take advantage of
creators and i think one of the
most important things is reading
contracts or if you're not going to read
the thing in entirety
find yourself an incredible lawyer that
can do that on your behalf
i know some of you guys might be just
starting out and you can't afford to
have a lawyer you can't have
and all of these things seem so just out
of reach
it does take time and i
can't even stress enough like i've
honestly been making youtube videos
since 2006
that is longer than some of you have
been alive so can we just
maybe put that into perspective there's
something else that kind of
has upset me a little bit but i think
it's kind of more of a personal thing is
that i sometimes feel
bad for having success like it's a very
very strange thing i wouldn't say it's
imposter syndrome because
i do feel like i belong here i've worked
very hard to get to where i am
so i think it's more like i don't want
other people to feel bad
for not being successful or have not
reached that level of success that
i feel like i'm at right now i do feel
like there is so much more that i can be
doing
there are so many things that i could
have done better i could be doing better
but it really sometimes just comes down
to how i'm feeling if i personally
don't want to make a video it's really
really hard to do so and i think that's
one of the things that i'm kind of
working
on in the next couple of years is how
can i
still be creating content but while
having other source of income
that doesn't rely around me i think
that's one of the biggest
issues that a lot of us have fallen into
is these businesses rely on us they rely
on our mood they rely on our health
they rely so much on you that
if it wasn't for you they couldn't exist
so that's kind of something
that i would really stress to a lot of
you is if you had to take yourself out
of the picture
what would happen if you weren't there
and i'm still kind of struggling with
that because this channel really is
based on me because this channel still
is based
on me and i'm the one talking to you
guys so
it may look a little bit different in
the future it may stay the same
it's really hard to say i know a lot of
you guys have asked me
a bunch of questions about this so i'm
gonna pop in here
and see if i can answer a couple of them
for you but as we go if you guys think
of any questions feel free to ask them
in the comments
send me a tweet and if you guys would be
interested maybe i'll do
a little uh live stream and i can answer
some of the questions
you guys have for you live so this first
question is actually
from trisha who has been also making
content for a very long time
and it's really cool to sort of see
creators like trisha
and some of my other youtuber friends
who continue
to create who continue to inspire me to
create
and have also found ways to stay
relevant for so long which is
one of her questions is how you've
managed to stay on top of various
platform changes and adapt your content
to be successful
in every iteration queen well trisha
thank you you are also
a queen there's a lot to unpack here
kind of in this question is
obviously how i've stayed on top of all
of the various platform changes
is it's very difficult and then also
adapting my content
to be successful is a whole nother
kind of take because i know the type of
videos that do well on my channel
but sometimes those aren't the ones that
i want to create so that is
the battle i feel like every youtuber
kind of falls into because i
loved creating vlogs i loved sort of
sharing my
daily activities or travels and
adventures and those just for some
reason
stopped performing well on my channel so
what i found though is people really
enjoyed the tech reviews so i tried to
find a way to merge those two things
together is how can i do a tech review
but also do a vlog
and unboxings are fun but they kind of
were getting boring and just repetitive
like okay great look i'm opening
something up here it is
so the type of videos that i'd like to
watch were okay you opened up this thing
go outside test it out give us real life
experiences
and show us how it works so really when
it comes down to the type of content
that i'm creating
i'm creating content that i want to
watch while also trying to figure out
how to appease
the youtube algorithm which is a whole
other mystery but
trial and error and just know that guess
what some videos are going to do well
and some aren't and sometimes
there really isn't an explanation and i
think that's one of the most difficult
things
to sometimes really comprehend like you
just can't actually figure out why
why did this video not do well i know
some of you guys are very analytical i
am not
a huge analytics person and i know a lot
of you are probably cringing like
justine you could learn so much from
your analytics
yes that's true but i got to the point
where i became so
obsessed with the numbers that
it kind of took away from the joy of
creating content
and for me keeping myself inspired
and excited about creating content was
almost more important to me
than looking at the numbers obviously
numbers are very important because it
kind of is the whole name of the game
of creating content you need to have the
subscribers you need to have the numbers
and the views and the eyeballs but
finding that fine balance of not being
obsessive while still enjoying creating
content that you want to create
it's difficult and it's something that i
do deal with on a weekly basis you do
have to be ready to change at any point
because things do
move so quickly that a lot of times what
maybe worked yesterday
might not work tomorrow like my entire
mentality has just been i'm not gonna
quit
so i'm just gonna keep doing this so if
something isn't kind of working
it's really fun because you get to
experiment and you get to try different
things and see what works and see what
doesn't because with that mentality
you're not going to quit so you just
kind of keep going this one is from ryan
and he's asking
how does one find their voice in terms
of deciding what kind of videos to make
you like making sketches and short
narratives but you also started liking
video game streaming so what's great
about youtube people love
watching people talk about things that
they're passionate about i mean i know
if there's something that i'm interested
in like i recently have been obsessed
with rubik's cubes
so i've been searching for like rubik's
cubes unboxings and tutorials and tips
and tricks and watching people who are
so passionate and so knowledgeable about
the topic and the subject of
solving rubik's cubes is just so
fascinating because you can really tell
that this is something that someone
loves so creating content
about something that you love something
that you're knowledgeable and passionate
about it really does
shine through in your videos and for you
guys
i think one of the well it's like kind
of a compliment but also
kind of not people will say that i'm too
over
excited about something and i'm like
that's great because
this is genuinely how i feel when i'm
unboxing something or showing you guys a
product so while some people might take
offense to that i'm like you're right i
am hyped i am excited and it's great
that you guys can actually feel that
through the screen and to touch on
finding your voice
that is something that kind of comes
over time because i
have had so many iterations of content i
mean i used to make cooking videos
which were something that i really
really enjoyed but for me those cooking
videos were kind of
the pieces to the puzzle that were
missing in between the tech videos
so i feel like before i wasn't doing as
much tech because i didn't have
all of the connections that i do now
since i kind of switched my channel over
to focusing a lot more on tech and it
also seems like the industry is also
growing quicker so there are so many
more tech products out so i feel like
the need to do those cooking videos
wasn't as important because i had so
much stuff to make content about
that those just kind of were the filler
videos and i honestly
also started not enjoying making them as
much so it's kind of this battle that i
had with myself like okay i know
you guys really enjoy them but for me i
wasn't enjoying them as much
and most recently i actually did do a
cooking video and i was like
i kind of miss this so don't ever rule
out
something like that coming back here
because who knows
maybe my tech channel is going to go
back to cooking again and that also kind
of goes back to like how i'm feeling
like i can't
sit here and make a video if it's
something that i don't want to do and
that is a
personality trait for me that
has helped but also i think hindered
a lot of things uh like in school like i
really struggled
with you know getting good grades for
classes that i didn't
enjoy but those classes that i did like
like computer programming and art and
photography and yearbook and all of
those things
oh you better believe i excelled very
very well at those ones
so for me like knowing myself and how i
work is
really important because i sometimes
need to bring in other people to sort of
fill in those spaces
of things that i know that i'm unable to
complete
i think another question that a lot of
people ask is about my team
like what just what do the people around
me look like like who else do i work
with
probably surprising to people that i do
have a very small team i know a lot of
youtubers have you know massive teams of
people that are editing and doing
thumbnails and all of the stuff
mine is still very small i still edit a
lot of my videos
but i'm grateful that my friend tyler
works with me as well he does shoot
and helps edit as well and then my
sister and i both do a podcast together
so she
also sometimes edits the podcast and
then tyler will also sometimes edit the
podcast and i will also sometimes edit
so it is a very small team
but it is a team effort and i'm very
grateful for both of them
who assist almost daily on whether it's
shooting or editing or just random tasks
that need to get done so then outside of
that
i do have a management team that i've
been working with for
wow oh my gosh a very long time you guys
might remember patara who has been in
some of my vlogs back in the day
we've been working together for a very
very long time and then i also
do have an agency which is wme who i've
been with for a couple of years they
work more in sort of the scripted doing
some bigger brand deals
and they don't do so much the day to day
whereas my management team call them
like my babysitting team
because i am not very good at keeping
myself on track sometimes
like i said knowing my faults and
knowing my downfalls and they are there
to sort of
fill in those blanks and help me keep on
track
post things on time and kind of do the
day-to-day working with the brands and
kind of negotiating on my behalf
is incredibly helpful and then one of
and then another very important piece of
the puzzle is
i do have an incredible law firm when i
first started
the first maybe five or six years i had
nothing i had no one i was reading all
of the contracts myself
i was calling in favors from friends so
it really was
a lot of people who were kind of just
helping me so i'm very very grateful for
when i first started out for all the
people who were just so kind and
generous to
to offer their time and their energy to
help me sort of navigate this new world
because this was something that was
nothing like there was no one doing this
so even the lawyer friends that i had
were like we've never
really done this type of stuff before we
don't really
understand entirely and i'm like well i
don't understand either because
this is a whole kind of new world so the
brand deals that i'm getting now i mean
obviously are so completely different
from what i was getting in like 2006
even up until 2010 i feel like the
landscape now has kind of leveled off
like there is
some sort of standard whereas before i
mean we were just making it up as we
went
and i'm sure some of you guys are
questioning like well what does an
actual
deal look like does vary between
different brands and companies because
a lot of times i might be doing a
project for said brand then there's an
agency
in between and then that agency is
talking to my agency and then
they talk to me so there's a potential
for a lot of disconnect
in between there so it really is always
great when you can talk to the brand
directly and be able to hear
this is their vision this is what they
want to come across in the video and
it's really fun because i feel like at
this point i've kind of earned
enough of that street cred of okay
listen you have this idea
i don't think that's gonna go over so
well with my audience
so it's kind of keeping you guys in mind
and
knowing that like if i said what those
people wanted me to say
you guys are gonna make fun of me you're
gonna make fun of the brand and we can't
be having any of that
so sometimes those deals will be just a
specific youtube video sometimes it'll
just be instagram or sometimes it'll be
a youtube video plus a couple of tweets
plus
facebook plus a tick tock maybe a
snapchat maybe some instagram stories
so it's like every deal kind of looks a
little bit different and a lot of times
it will really start with okay
how much budget does the brand have and
what can we kind of do for that
so really every kind of project is sort
of tailored towards like what the brand
is looking for
what is their messaging are they giving
you guys a discount are they buying
something then there's also the whole
other side of things of affiliate links
so affiliate links
are when somebody clicks on a link and
then you
get money if they buy something so
sometimes we'll work with brands to do
affiliate links where i'll get a
percentage of whatever you guys purchase
and then also there's just the basic
amazon affiliate links which i do use
in the description there's a website
called genius links that i use
which is kind of cool because when you
click on the genius link it will then
take you to an affiliate link of
wherever you guys are located so just
know that when you guys do click on
affiliate links from creators you are
helping out the creator so if there is
something that you're looking to buy go
find one of your favorite content
creators and use their links because it
definitely does help out
the next question is from renee who is
asking how i've stayed so positive
and optimistic over the years i feel
like in my content
and everything that i create that is
something that i really strive to do
because that's the type of content that
i like to watch like i don't really like
watching drama videos i don't like
watching negative reviews
i like seeing positivity and i like you
know kind of spreading positivity
but i feel like that is
so far from i guess the actual
truth and like reality of creating
content because
i'm kind of thinking back to there's
been some times where i've
had to film videos where i've received
maybe like some of the worst news that
like a person could ever
like receive like you know in a text
message and you're just like
like i have these moments that are like
actually captured on film of like me
receiving
this has happened several times actually
of like some sort of news where you're
just like
it's a really weird thing like i don't
know if anybody has ever kind of like
experienced
that before as a creator um i do
tend to try to keep most of my private
life kind of like off of
like the internet which is very strange
because i was somebody who shared
everything like i vlogged
almost every single day and that sort of
turned me into somebody i feel like that
i didn't like and
having sort of that experience of like
feeling myself
become someone who i didn't like and
that was creating
content for the sake of creating content
and not
living it's such a weird strange thing
it's hard to explain if you've never
really experienced this but i'm sure
maybe
you as a viewer or a consumer who have
watched a lot of your favorite youtubers
over the years who have maybe daily
vlogged and kind of just like sort of
seen that
demise that downfall like you can just
see it in somebody's eyes so i guess
going back to kind of
getting that type of news and sort of
not only is it
traumatizing getting that type of news
but trying to
take yourself out of that situation of
receiving that news and knowing that you
have to finish
shooting this video before you can deal
with what you just
were dealt with there's been times where
i've had to
go to set the next day after finding out
like a very close friend had passed away
it was still something that
kind of just i think about a lot is how
difficult it was for me to kind of you
know find out this news
you're grieving and you go to set
because there's
no way that this thing could have been
rescheduled there's so
much relying on you being at this
i'll never forget like going to the set
and shooting all day and then
it was like the last take and i just
freaking like i couldn't do it anymore
like i just broke down crying i was like
i'm so
sorry because it was like all day i was
like fighting
how i was feeling to just try to power
through for the sake of you know getting
this project done
there were so many people involved i
think being on a channel like this where
things do revolve around you it's
very very difficult to sometimes just
know that like
you kind of have to sometimes put your
feelings aside to get things done
because a lot of things are riding on
specific projects or
keeping your channel going and i think
it's finding that balance
of work life and
making sure that you're not ignoring
like those feelings
of grief or whatever it is because these
things do revolve around us
and you guys look to us for that
inspiration or for that content and
you know if we're not in a good place
for you like we're definitely not in a
good place for ourselves there's another
question
right after this where josh was asking
was there a point where you almost quit
making videos or considered doing
something else
there was some points where i felt uh
i guess i just kind of felt like i
wasn't enjoying
making videos as much as i used to i
knew that this was something that i
loved
but i couldn't figure out like what was
it why was i not enjoying it and because
i had started taking on too many
projects i it
was running like four or five channels
at the time i was doing
daily gaming videos i was doing daily
videos and i was focusing on
too much i had so much on my plate i
went back to the drawing board i'm now
gonna only do one channel
i'm gonna focus on this and what are the
things that make me happy like what do i
love
and why did i start making youtube
videos to begin with and
i came to the conclusion that like i
made videos because
i enjoyed it i made videos because i
wanted to share information i wanted to
feel connected to people and i also made
them because i wanted to make people
laugh as well i thought like all right
what are my favorite things and at this
point i think this might have been
around like
2000 maybe 2016 2015 no because after i
got my dog
so it was probably 2016. i was like all
right
your girl she likes video games she
likes
tech she likes food and she freaking
loves her dog
and she loves traveling so i basically
went like that and i just started
changing everything that i was doing on
my channel to everything that i loved
and i
instantly like started seeing like my
numbers going back up but the engagement
going up and you guys
seemed to start enjoying the content
more and it was because i started
creating stuff that i was passionate
about
this goes back to the beginning of the
video where i was talking about
finding that passion and creating videos
because it's something that you want to
create and i know that's really hard
because
sometimes the algorithm doesn't reward
that type of content
so how can you kind of do both and
sometimes the type of content that
you're creating
it will never be something that reaches
a wide audience it can be something so
niche or so specific
that not everyone is going to be
interested in that thing but what's cool
is because
that said topic may be so small you can
work and strive to
be the number one search result for
whatever it is
that you're interested in so i just
can't stress enough about finding your
passion and just
really going with it and maybe it's not
creating content maybe it's just
in your everyday day-to-day life looking
for a job like what is it
that motivates you like what is it that
makes you happy and just really
figure out a way to sort of make that a
part of your everyday life make it your
job make it your career and it's not
going to be easy at all like it's not
and if it is easy then that's amazing
and you're super lucky and you should be
very grateful
for having an easy and not so
challenging time
whereas most of the time there are tons
of ups and downs and if you are
experiencing a down right now
just know there's only one other way to
go and that's up
so i don't know this video has kind of
taken some turns i think i
actually got a little emotional at some
point and uh also
not even sure if it's gonna make the
video or not because uh
i lost my audio halfway through this
video
and so some of the stuff that i planned
on talking about
there's no audio for it so i don't even
remember what i said if i had to tell my
2000 self what would you tell her about
the journey you've gone through
honestly i would just tell her like
watch this video and just
know that like you're gonna go through
some crap it's not gonna be good
but it's gonna be rewarding you're gonna
have a journey
of a lifetime and you know everything
that's gonna happen to you
is it's gonna happen for a reason and
each one of those things that have
happened to me
over the course of the past like 20
years of leading up to where i am right
now
i'm also just to share with you guys in
case you're curious i'm
36 i will be 37 i have seen
a lot and there's still much more to be
seen
and i've learned so much over the past
like 20 plus years
that i would tell little justine so many
things
but none of it would actually really i
think make a difference because
we don't necessarily listen to our
parents until it's too late and there's
so many of you out there that are
probably like my parents have told me
this justine you're telling me this
and none of this is even gonna make any
sense until you are in a position where
something has happened
and you learn from that and you're like
man justine told me this or
oh my gosh my mom or my dad or my
grandparents or somebody
warned me about this thing and it's not
going to make any sense to you until you
actually
really learn it yourself unless you are
one of those people who actually do
listen to
advice and and listen to your parents
and know that they're probably
most likely correct because they have
lived
through so much and have seen so much so
that's something that i think i've
learned
way too late in life is like a lot of
times
a lot of people older than us have seen
so many things and what they're telling
us
is probably just for our own good so
that we don't make the same mistakes
that they've made
but uh if we don't make the mistakes
then we don't actually learn
do we staff is asking if there's
anything that i would change
kind of looking back and i don't think
there is because
things that i do regret are what have
kind of like made me who i am today and
some of those things that i might have a
slight regret on
i mean if i would have done something
differently something else
good in my life might not have happened
or something else so there's just so
many trajectories i feel like that you
can sort of take
for me just kind of going with it and
knowing that i
am strong enough to figure out anything
that's thrown at me whether it's good
whether it's bad like it's gonna work
out it might take some time it might
take a lot of work
but that's kind of been my mentality
of most of my life and i've somehow
figured it out and i think this
generation and even the younger
generation like
we have already been dealt with so much
over just the past year i feel like the
entire world has completely changed so
we've had to shift we've had to adapt
and it's been really amazing to see so
many young people kind of step up and
try to figure out this whole new world
so it's like you guys
you really are the future so when people
say i really want to be a youtuber i'm
like no
no you need to think bigger you need to
think broader because this career that i
have right now
was not a career when i was looking to
start a career you know with other
content creators but because i was so
early i mean we were really figuring
this out from the beginning and making
it as we went
and that is something that i really want
to challenge
a lot of you guys think bigger like
think of what's not out there and create
it and become it and be the best at it
and
i know that you can do it because i did
it i know so many of you guys
out there have that will and that drive
that you are going to create
the next thing so i look forward to
hopefully still being around
when you do create it well thank you
guys again for watching this video there
are some things that i
feel like i didn't actually get to say
to you because i lost my audio and then
i don't remember what i
said but i know i definitely almost
cried at one point
i'm just so incredibly grateful to be
able to have this opportunity to sit
here to talk to you to influence you but
mostly i just want to thank you for
letting me
i guess kind of find my place here
online because when i grew up i didn't
know
what i wanted to do i didn't have a lot
of friends a lot of people didn't like
the same things that i liked
so being able to find this community of
people that are accepting and like the
same things
as i like has just been so incredibly
rewarding and life-changing and
i just honestly can't thank you guys
enough so thank you to you guys for
watching and also thank you so much to
brands who
support creators because without them it
would be so much more difficult to be
able to create the type of content that
we want to create and to keep
entertaining for you guys
so again thank you i am forever so so
grateful
and i would love to keep this
conversation going because i know you
guys are probably going to have a lot
more questions
so leave them in the comments below
tweet me and i do want to do a follow up
live stream so that i can actually
kind of have a real dialogue a real
conversation and answer some more of
your questions
so thank you guys for watching i'll see
you guys later bye
[Music]